I better look like a freshly born Gerber
baby if I'm going to be spending $2
million on anti-aging hacks hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen in today's video we'll be taking
a look at Tech sent to millionaire Brian
Johnson's biohacking longevity blueprint
that promises to turn back the hands of
time a huge thank you to Eric Williamson
of unlocked Fitness and Nutrition who
helped me in the research on this video
so if you're looking for any kind of
one-on-one nutrition support for weight
loss or Fitness Nutrition they really
are my go-to team so I am going to be
linking all of their links below and if
you are new here definitely don't forget
to Please Subscribe and you can check
out my free Hunger crushing combo ebook
and my new protein ebook in the
description below okay so Brian Johnson
aka the most most measured man has spent
$2 million working with a team of 30
doctors to basically Benjamin Button
himself over the past 2 years in results
that he made available to the public he
apparently slowed the aging process down
by about 31 years and achieved a body
inflammation level 85% below your
average 18-year-old I mean my te years
were not my healthiest so I'm not sure
that that would be a really great Roi
for me personally but definitely
impressive nonetheless and based on his
own extensive investment and success he
created a longevity blueprint protocol
that he shares widely online so today
we're going to be unpacking its main
components with a little science andas
okay let me hop in here quickly to tell
you about my sponsor today Thrive market
so this time of year is challenging for
a lot of people because we are extra
motivated to eat well and take care of
our bodies but the price of groceries
is kind of insane but if you haven't
heard of Thrive Market get excited
because it really has changed the game
for me so Thrive Market is an amazing
online membership based grocery store
that aims to make Health Focus Specialty
Products more affordable and accessible
to everyone they are a One-Stop shop
offering foods and snacks eco-friendly
kitchen and cleaning supplies Beauty
items supplements home goods and
everything in between most of the year I
live here in Canada but as soon as I get
down to the States I order my Thrive box
because there are just so many amazing
products that you cannot get anywhere
else basically you can filter by over 90
different diets Lifestyles and values
like vegan fair trade gluten-free and
more they also have an amazing selection
of sustainable Seafood wine and
nutritious snacks that my kids love
every time I order I discover a handful
of new products that basically become
instant Staples for us and the best part
is all items are less expensive than
traditional retail they price match and
me members make back their annual $60
membership in savings and for whatever
reason you don't Thrive will credit you
the difference I also love their
commitment to sustainability so not only
a shipping on orders over $49 free but
everything is delivered with carbon
neutral shipping and from their zero
waste warehouses another thing I really
love about Thrive is that for every paid
annual membership the Thrive gives
initiative gives away a free membership
to a lowincome family teacher Andor
veteran there's really so many reasons
to feel good about ordering from Thrive
so if you want to save some money on
really unique Health Products this year
check out the link in my description
thrivemarket.com
slabby sharp to get 30% off of your
first order and a free gift worth up to
$60 biohack number one is consuming 2250
calories per day with a 10% calorie
deficit so we often see suggestions that
a calorie restricted diet is associated
with longer life because a calorie
deficit slows our metabolism slows cell
turnover and increases autophagy and
other processes that help to clean out
damaged and dysfunctional proteins so we
see tons of examples of this in the
animal research where for example
monkeys who are given a diet with a 25%
deficit from around adolescence to the
end of their life lived approximately 3
years or around
11.5% longer if this were translated
into humans and added 11.5% % to the
average American life length of 79 would
mean us living to 88 instead I think
this is what the kids these days would
describe as so clutch immediately know
immediately know but alas we're not
monkeys so in human research like the
calorie study participants were
prescribed a 25% calorie deficit for 2
years now a 25% deficit for two whole
years is kind of an insane ask so
participants only achieved a 12% deficit
on average however even with that
deficit they found reductions in
metabolism lower inflammatory markers
and lower cardiovascular risk factors
also those who stuck to the calorie
deficit of at least 10% saw the Aging of
their DNA AKA DNA methylation slowed
down by 2 to 3% not quite the effect
that we're seeing in animals like
monkeys but if followed over an entire
adult lifetime it could be at least 2
years gained in life so sure caloric
restriction for longevity is supported
by evidence it may not be direct
evidence because we can't force people
to restrict their calories until they
die but we do have indicators suggesting
that it may help to reduce risk of early
death and early disease that said you
kind of have to decide if being on a
diet until you die is worth maybe
getting two more extra years it's
definitely enough for me though but if
you do you want to attempt a weight loss
diet it is imperative that you are
incorporating resistance exercise into
your regimen since humans are a lot more
susceptible to loss of muscle and bone
than most animals biohack number two
fast for 16 to 18 hours per day so we
have covered fasting in a lot of detail
in this video right here and if you
recall the main takeaways from my video
were a that it can help some people but
not everyone with managing their weight
and B early Tim restricted feeding where
you cut off your feeding window before
the evening can improve insulin
sensitivity and metabolic health and C
longer fasts risk muscle loss if not
doing a lot of resistance training and
consuming adequate protein so as with
most diets if it lowers your risk of
obesity and or improves insulin
sensitivity it typically lowers your
risk of diseases that may lead to early
death but there are two other unique
factors that may explain how fasting
could improve your longevity in humans
one is that it reduces oxidative stress
so this comes back to damaged and
dysfunctional proteins and their role in
aging so if we kind of go back to grade
10 science class oxidative stress is the
creation of molecules that are missing
an electron so these molecules then
steal electrons from important cells
leaving those cells damaged and
dysfunctional now oxidative stress is
actually one of the main theories of
Aging so anything that can reduce
oxidative stress is said to help and
early Tim restricted feeding so again
basically a fasting window where you eat
your breakfast you have your lunch but
you skip dinner likely reduces that
oxidative stress unfortunately this is
not how most people do intermittent
fasting right now the second aspect of
fasting that's associated with longevity
is a term that all the Tik Tok Wellness
gurus love to overuse autophagy so this
is the process of those damaged and
dysfunctional protein gen being cleaned
up and removed again the benefit here is
with that early Tim restricted feeding
where research suggest that it increased
aoy gene expression by about 10 to 20% a
full 36-hour Fast and you might even be
able to bump that up to 20 to 30% now
interestingly these numbers are
relatively small when compared to
exercise where we're looking at an over
100% increase and personally I like
exercise a lot more than not eating for
a day and a half now it's important to
know though that there is such thing as
too much autophagy as this published
cartoon depiction from the Journal of
autophagy shows we want to prevent a
mess from oxidative stress and like
clean it up but we can actually go too
far to the point that we lose healthy
cells and or loss of important cellular
organs like the mitochondria it's also
really important to know that there are
loads of causes of oxid stress like
pollutants obesity processed foods and
even psychological stress and there are
a lot of behaviors that can reduce
oxidative stress and increase autophagy
so things like exercise like we
discussed sleep Stress Management and
eating a nutrient-dense diet high in
antioxidants intermittent fasting
actually has a relatively small effect
and it's kind of impossible to quantify
exactly how much without teasing out the
weight loss benefits but even if we just
compare its autophagy benefits to those
from exercise it's hard to make an
argument that you should skip dinner for
the rest of your life in my opinion
anyway so yeah this is up to you if you
decide it's a habit worth your sanity
okay bioh hack number three eating 70
lbs of vegetables per month okay so 70
lb is a kind of big scary number I mean
I kind of feel bloated just thinking
about it but it ends up working out to
about 2.3 lb or a kilog per day so in a
day that would be equivalent to you
consuming one whole head of celery 10
cups of kale and 3 cups of chopped sweet
potatoes which is definitely still a lot
but if you were super committed it could
be done but does it have to well the
American Heart Association recommends
four to five servings of fruits and
vegetable per day based on huge studies
like this and this and as you can see
your risk of early death significantly
dein lines once you reach about five
servings of produce and then after that
your return on investment isn't really
that great each serving of vegetables in
these studies is around 80 g so most of
the effect on enhancing longevity is
around 400 G that is less than a pound
and far less than 2.3 lb the for a gram
recommendation is also supported by a
modeling study using multiple
metaanalysis that found that 400 G of
vegetables per day would increase the
lifespan by about 6 months if
implemented around the age of 45 now
while his suggestion of consuming nearly
2 and a half times this amount is likely
Overkill at least from a direct
longevity standpoint there's really no
risk to this and I can also just
understand wanting to have extra
vegetables that are high in nutrients
water and fiber to try to keep him full
if he's trying to constantly maintain a
10% calorie deficit fiber and volume
Rich veg is really getting key when
trying to diet biohack number four a
specific macro ratio of 90% protein 33%
carbs and 48% fat this is wildly
specific and must be somehow tailored to
his needs based on all of the excessive
medical testing he's had done as we
discussed in our video on Macros protein
is usually the most important
macronutrient to manipulate based on
your goals protein protein protein
protein protein protein protein at 90%
of his calories from protein he's
getting around 108 gr of protein per day
or just under 1.5 g of protein per
kilogram of body weight which is close
to what's ideal for muscle gain a little
low for supporting weight loss but is
totally in the clear for good health now
I noticed Brian cited Stu Phillips paper
on Optimum protein intakes for health
which suggests a range of 1.2 to 1.6 G
per kilogram so that maybe explains
where he gets his number now this
specific ratios for carbs and fat
however are a lot less important than
where you're getting your carbs and fats
from that is we want whole nutrient
dense options which he obviously seems
to fulfill beautifully his diet actually
looks quite close to a Mediterranean
style diet with a variety of colors
plenty of fiber and lots of
phytonutrients from plant-based Foods
now we've talked before about how
caloric restriction possibly could add 2
plus years optimal veggie intake take
adding 05 years and Inter fasting maybe
adding sometime too but unlikely to have
a huge effect especially for someone
who's already quite fit and healthy but
all of this pales in comparison to
eating a whole food diet rich in whole
greens legumes fruits and veggies
research suggest that this dietary
pattern can add an additional 11.7 years
to your life when compared to a western
diet if implemented at age 40 now that
seems like a good Roi finally biohack
number five is taking 100 plus pills per
day I'm pretty good at swallowing pills
but I'm feeling just a little bit gaggy
thinking about
that I'm not going to dive into this
extensive list of pills most of which
are supplements but some of which are
actually drugs like metformin but there
is no question there are a lot of great
supplements on his list here uh cocoa
flavanols ashwagandha DHEA D3 three even
P protein but my general messaging on
supplements is that a simple and
streamlined supplement regimen can
really be helpful for a lot of folks in
taking the stress out of eating
perfectly for their goals 100
supplements on the other hand like I
can't think of a more stressful
expensive and logistically intense
Endeavor like you would need a whole
supplement Pantry just to store
everything so yeah this is just not
realistic for anyone who isn't a c a
million
now obviously his website is a treasure
Trove of intense Data Tracking and
protocol details if you're interested in
every test he's run how much he spent
and what his results have been but
outside of his Ode to Sleep which I
agree on is key I didn't see a whole lot
of focus on mental or social health and
that's kind of important when we look at
big studies like this one we see that
the number and strength of our
relationships are even better better
predictors of our longevity than
anything that is physical health related
same with having a sense of purpose in
life and optimism which can add as much
as 12 years to our lives but with all
that said what we can take away is that
from a nutrition perspective at least
the most impactful thing that we can do
is choosing a mostly whole food
nutrient-dense diet some people may find
that the trade-off of choric restriction
optimal macros and Inter fasting worth
it for some smaller effects but if it's
impacting your mental health or leading
us to not be able to spend quality time
with our family and friends affecting
our happiness and relationships then it
could actually end up having an overall
detrimental effect so that was my
professional opinion my personal opinion
is to fasting and dieting and like get a
hobby make a new friend live your best
life there's really not a whole lot of
point in living an extra year or two if
you are anxious and miserable as but on
that note thank you again to Eric
Williamson for helping with today's
script I'm leaving a link below for his
information if you're looking for any
one-on-one weight loss or finished
nutrition Support also leave me a
comment below on your longevity or
biohacking thoughts subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
aby's kitchen
[Music]
bye